sudan and ethiopia are facing off in a
border confrontation that could redraw
the map of east africa
on the surface the dispute seems simple
with both sides claiming al-fashaga a
valuable region of farmland as their own
but look deeper and the situation is
more complex
the war in tigre the struggle over the
nile the eritrea factor egypt all of
these things just make for a much more
combustible
mix ethiopia is already embroiled in a
brutal civil war
a new international conflict would prove
devastating not just for ethiopia but
the entire region
al-fasharga
a stolen land from both sides
perspectives a stolen land that has been
retaken by force
[Music]
as with many borders in africa the
problems began with the british
while ethiopia remained independent for
most of the colonial era sudan was
colonized by britain
eager to demarcate its new territory
britain drew the border between ethiopia
and sudan in 1902
and one area was a bone of contention
from the beginning alpha saga
alfa saga area which is around 250
kilometers is extremely fertile and
europa farmers used to grow sesame seeds
one of the main export items for addis
ababa
even though the region was inhabited by
both ethiopian and sudanese farmers the
british claimed the area as part of
sudan
a decision that many ethiopians never
accepted
the way the ethio sudan border has been
demarcated
is problematic from the get-go it cuts
across same communities
that shares same values culture custom
language tradition and sometimes even
religion
over the decades tensions on the border
have regularly erupted into violence
but in 2008 a landmark treaty was agreed
al-fasaga was recognized by both sides
as sudanese
but in return ethiopian farmers would be
able to live and work freely in the
region both sides were pacified for a
while
but peace didn't hold for long
in 2018
ethiopia appointed a new prime minister
from the central region of the country
abi ahmed
he was seen as a reformist someone who
was liberalizing the country's politics
and its economy it brought his immense
hope and optimism both to the country
and and the region at large i mean we
talked at the time about abby mania he
was that popular and in 2019 he won a
nobel peace prize for his part in
seemingly settling a border disagreement
which had lasted for two decades between
ethiopia and eritrea
you
represent
a new generation of african leaders
despite his popularity abroad abby's
rise was resented by some at home
especially ethiopia's former ruling
party the tigray people's liberation
front and their supporters based in the
north of the country
keen to cement his leadership abby
wasted no time in criticizing his
predecessors
[Music]
that they were being scapegoated for
some of the the troubles of the previous
three decades authoritarianism
corruption so whilst much the country
welcomed the new prime minister
in tigre there was
apprehension and concern
which built up over the subsequent years
the situation came to a head in 2020
abby's government delayed a general
election citing the pandemic as the
cause
officials in tigre already mistrustful
of the government were furious and
decided to go ahead with their election
anyway
it was a direct challenge to abby's
leadership
well both sides started engaging in kind
of mutual delegitimization accusing the
other of being in power illegally in
november 2020. to graham forces attacked
federal military bases abby launched an
all-out assault on the region the
federal government
had every right
to deploy federal security forces
in an attempt to hamper rebel supply
lines into tigray abbey asked sudan to
seal the border between ethiopia and the
contested region of alpha shaga
sudan sensed an opportunity to claim
alpha saga once and for all
this is you know ethiopia at this point
was
was distracted it was plunging into a
civil conflict and it was weak so the
sudanese army went further than simply
securing the border they evicted
ethiopian farmers in the area they
heavily militarized the area
the farmers evicted by sudan were
amharas an ethnic group whose support
was vital to abi in his fight against
segre
now under a huge amount of pressure
abby's response was resolute
[Music]
ethiopia for the first time in in some
time claimed that this was in fact
ethiopian territory that this was an
invasion in this period of of of calm
has essentially been torn up now i mean
we're back to a point where both sides
lay claim to the territory you have
multiple different
armed forces
including ethnic militia in the area
which makes for an incredibly volatile
mix
after months of skirmishes sudan and
ethiopia are now at a standoff
it's a potentially explosive situation
especially as both countries are already
jostling for control of the region's
most precious resource water
the grand ethiopian renaissance dam has
also been contentious from the start
situated in ethiopia on the blue nile
just 20 kilometers from the sudanese
border the dam will transform ethiopia's
economy enabling it to export cheap
electricity to the whole region but for
downstream neighbors sudan and egypt who
rely on the blue nile ethiopia's control
of their water supply is deeply
unsettling
if the water that's coming to egypt
reduced by two percent at about one
million will be jobless
egypt who for whom denial is everything
are the waters of the nile it's
absolutely it's life lifeblood and
anything that potentially hinders it is
seen as a potential death knell for the
for the country
with concerns over the dam growing sudan
is increasingly siding with egypt
in 2021 the country's joined in a
military operation called guardians of
the nile
i think it's quite clear that the
sudanese have started to
to see the problems of the dam
through an egyptian lens to an extent
and they certainly started to express
their concerns regarding the safety of
their own damn downstream
so far efforts to bring sudan and
ethiopia to the table have been
unsuccessful
but some hope that the african union a
pan-african organization created to
promote peace could play a role in
encouraging both sides to step back from
the brink
we need to see a more meaningful
structured
mediation process that comes from the
africa union i think that will also pave
the way for similar contested borders to
be resolved in an unemployment
sustainable way so the international
community needs to support the african
union but i think
the initiative
the mediation process
the ownership should come from the
region itself
thanks for watching if you'd like to
read more of the economist east africa
coverage click the link and don't forget
to subscribe
you